breathing some podcasts value bad
[ __ ] the church what's
happening now is brought to you by CBD
lyin dot-com listen enough is enough you
can't buy CBD oil at a [ __ ] liquor
store right you go down there for a
bottle of whiskey like Oh CBD no it
don't [ __ ] work that way
there's professionals and there's
[ __ ] [ __ ] heels out there trying to
sell your [ __ ] maluca juice and tell
you it's CBD and there you are jumping
up and down I feel [ __ ] great little
do you know you're drinking [ __ ]
sugar water with somebody's permanent
that [ __ ] ends today alright CBD line is
the way to go for you I'm telling you
right now I've been working with these
guys for six months I've been using that
product for about eight months I reached
out to them why because when you gonna
CBD Lyon calm think I put third-party
test results they do everything from
start to finish
whether you want to smoke it drink it
eat a gummy [ __ ] CBD Lyon got you
covered
go to CBD line right now and press in
church BAM and get 20% off your first
order the church would also love to
welcome to the podcast expressvpn me
like joy what's Express BPM you ready it
runs in your background of your computer
or phone then you use the internet just
like you normally would you download the
app click to connect and viola you're
protected it shields your identity it
doesn't give them no tracking location
and you're totally totally totally
anonymous who else would come at you
with something like this uncle Joey cuz
I don't want no [ __ ] to know
where I am
and I don't want no [ __ ] know
where you are I heard it's really good
for international travel you gotta keep
these [ __ ] guessing you understand me
now do me a favor find out how you can
get three months listen to me three
months free gratis at expressvpn
dot-com slash Church that's expressed
vpm exp r e SS V p.m. dot-com slash
Church for three months free when you
buy a one-year package alright visit
expressvpn com
last Church to learn more and to take
back your privacy you hear me
stay black check this [ __ ]
mealy grab that bong head and set the
herb man free Rachel Wilson what's
happened beautiful thanks for having me
great to have you man how are you guys
good how are you I'm high I know you'll
make the strides in making a little
moves here and there I've been watching
you thank you 18 months and you open up
on a row for Felipe you're always
hustling I don't see no [ __ ] bikini
shots they're selling your ass working
on your merit and I really dig the hell
out of you so thank you for comin on the
show
highest of compliments I'm an honor to
be here
you know dawg i watch everything are you
people like what huh when can I come on
the podcast there's always a time in a
place yeah let me watch for a little
while let me see what the [ __ ] you're
doing and I you know I follow you on
twitter I see your tweets I see a little
morning thing you pop it up I read about
your family and that really interested
me and talking to you about your family
because I would die for them to adopt me
[Laughter]
I would die live with a judge a DA and
then your sister's like a top-notch
attorney she's a prosecutor she's a
prosecutor yeah so breakfast at that
[ __ ] house yes must be like
laws no they're in [ __ ] hoc to beat
the mill the [ __ ] the backhand slap
motion from 1988 listen that [ __ ] makes
my dick off there's evidence there's
objections there's literally you know my
mom was just a real estate attorney but
even just having a kid of an attorney
can be rough like a bit like their uh I
can't imagine having it from two sides
no one being a judge yeah my mom
definitely has like she's the [ __ ] and
balls like for sure there's a lot of
like you know intensity and you know
strong people in my family so what'd she
go to law school she went to law school
in San Diego are you dad
he went to law school here in Los
Angeles no sure and they met here
they met in the courthouse in Las Vegas
holy [ __ ] yeah my mom was a TV news
reporter and my dad was a prosecutor and
he would pass her in the hallway and he
always tells us that he would see her on
TV and say that he's gonna marry that
woman someday Wow and then she went off
to law school and I think they kind of
like we're dating other people and then
when she came back I guess they met at a
bar or something and like he couldn't
keep his hands off her that dog look
like Gordon Vegas must be completely
different than anywhere like Vegas is it
like a completely different I guess as
an insane like asylum I mean I don't
even know how I grew up there like I
went back last weekend and as you get
older you know your hometown means
different things you and you can kind of
put into perspective your childhood and
it's such a crazy place to grow up if
you think about it now as you growing up
to you we're your parents pushing for
you to go into the law field um I think
that was kind of something that was
maybe like an underlying expectation
people would always whenever I would see
them out or their co-worker would be
like oh are you gonna go to law school
you know do you want to be a lawyer when
you grow up and was like absolutely not
never so you knew it already I just knew
I wasn't that wasn't for me
I don't you got accepted into American
University I I went to college and went
to three colleges it was a small school
in Vermont called landmark college and
it's for people who have learning
disorders yeah I have ADHD so I learned
differently which is the nice way of
saying [ __ ] but I can say that I
have documentation so um but yeah I went
to a school that like taught me how to
learn cuz I just learned differently I
was always a creative person visual and
I just never I went to a bunch of
different middle schools and high
schools I went to a lockdown when I was
17 where I graduated from in Utah so I
my schooling was never it was it was all
over the place but you're very books
luck
I am emotionally smart I definitely have
a books if I like if I'm interested in
something I will become obsessed with it
but there's you couldn't pay me enough
money to ever study math ever again ever
I could give a thought yeah I did but
you didn't move the [ __ ] lot yeah
like we'd taught me math like the math
that I needed to know you know and I was
American University it was cool for like
you know it was cool to be in our
nation's capital
I got to see Obama get inaugurated like
I was a part of you know a huge
historical moment in time but I was I
just felt like the dumbest person in all
of my classes I could care less about
politics
I wasn't inspired by it I thought it was
kind of like Hollywood for ugly people
but I mean no there's whatever but I
just it wasn't the right place for me
and I even had the opportunity to intern
for Congress Congress I could have you
know gone off and done something big
with that but I just was never it wasn't
meant for me so you ended up in Lynn
College lopata Florida Boca ratone and
that's where you got your degree I got
my master's degree from Lynn and yeah I
stayed down there and I worked in the
hospitality industry I always work since
I was 15 in hospitality and I worked in
marketing out of college and you got a
degree in market yeah a master's a
master's yeah marketing no [ __ ] yeah and
then what did you start smoking reefer
as soon as I pretty much left my parents
house when I went to college nineteen
when I was Vermont
yeah that's words I mean you have to
smoke
that's the place like everyone is on
something and then when did you first
decide to get on stage um almost three
years ago yeah um when I was 29 yeah
what made you want to go cuz you said
you I had tried to get on stage many
years before that I did improv as a kid
so performing was never I was never shy
performing I was always the first
wedding
College who wanted to like get up and do
my presentations and I just liked being
in front of people but when I was living
in Florida I started going to improv
shows my first stand-up show was seeing
Mike Epps at the Palm Beach improv and I
would see I saw Jon Lovitz Bob Saget
like I had just fell in love with
stand-up years ago and then it wasn't
until I was just in these like horrible
relationships I was working these
corporate jobs out here that I just was
terrible at and I just knew that I
really won felt purposeless I felt like
I was just kind of aimlessly roaming
through life I I like you know I really
spoke to my depression and just I think
I just I was searching for that
something and it wasn't until I was
getting out of a relationship I was 29 I
was living with this guy that was so
toxic and my life just wasn't what I
wanted it to look like and for something
for some reason just like stand-up was
like it was screaming inside me it was
like do stand-up and I had seen a friend
my friend Sam grody she was a sorority
sister with me in DC she does stand-up
and I went to see her at the Jon Lovitz
Club that one that got shut down
universe yeah Universal and I saw her
perform it was like I could definitely
do and so yeah I ended up finally after
a breakup I just started writing I went
to Mike's I yeah I started getting
onstage are you I don't know how to ask
you this are you lucky in love am i
lucky in love like at love I have always
you attract the [ __ ] knucklehead
I've attracted a variety of men in my
life some of them were men some of them
questionable I've always been in
relationships since I was 15 years old
I've always like loved having boyfriends
I've dated people since I was 15 so I've
had a bunch of boyfriends I guess I've
had experience in dating guys
who were all different kinds of healthy
and unhealthy for me
now when you broke up with that one dude
nothing to stand up like I did the same
thing like it was all part of a
metamorphosis process it was all part of
her I'm gonna stop doing what the [ __ ]
I'm doing and get into this like right I
got on stage and like June and then
October she told me she wanted to get
separated
oh wow so I walked like four four months
I walked around like I don't want to be
with this person no more and everything
sucked yeah
like everything just sucked once I got
on stage and Here I am 28 I'm out of
prison and I'm with this woman and god
bless her she drove me to my first open
wide she forced me like she forced the
hand you know but it's really tough to
explain to people sometimes that you're
like I got understand that but the
lowest point in my life and then I got
into it at a lower point and then I got
all in at the lowest point in my life
what the lure I got the more I got into
it yeah is that how you found sometimes
I my first year standup I suffered like
suicidal depression like I wasn't like I
didn't have a plan I wouldn't actually
do it but it it was in and out of my
life my first year as stand-up I got out
of that relationship that I was in at 29
started stand-up it was I was working
for levity at the time and my I was
doing social media marketing for them
that's really like my my path into
comedy was like I used to work at
corporate and I I ended up leaving that
job because they wanted to bring someone
in-house they got Rita from The Improv
let me be a bartender in the lab and
they don't give those jobs to like just
anyone let alone women and like I'm not
a career bartender like I'm in the back
looking up you know basic recipes for a
Manhattan
you know what I mean like she really
believed in me and so I was going
through this breakup she gave me an
opportunity at the improv and I was also
starting my open mics and writing and
getting into stand-up and it just became
like my I was like this is what I'm in
love with this is this is what I've been
missing my whole life this is what this
is my purpose it gave me meaning to my
life in a whole new way
oddly enough I ended up getting into
another relationship this past year I
just got out of a relationship but he
works in comedy and I just like I just
fell in love with comedy like that was
like my that was my main love and then
everything else was secondary and like
he kind of saw that process of like my
first year is rut was rough for me
because I was going through kind of just
like everything in my life like okay now
I'm in a place where I can put meaning
and like finding the funny in my pain
and my trauma and also just like you
know I think it's a crutch for me as
some of these relationships like I've
always just maybe been afraid to be
fully independent like which I know I
can be but like who wants to be alone at
night you know what I mean like and I
don't I'm not a random casual sex person
it just doesn't fulfill me so I think
that the more that I fell in love with
stand-up the like less like my
relationship became began to deteriorate
it was so weird to me how do you think
about the first five or six years of a
stand-up you know you're in love with
something when you give up your
apartment yeah like you know you're in
love with something like you have to
force your you have to force yourself to
not be on yeah like I can't be almond I
don't even know what that is no like if
there were nights that I would choose to
like spend in my first years I would
have this guilty feeling like I'm
cheating on my like my love you know
what Amy and and I and like that's when
I was like okay
is this is something that means so much
to me
and it's just like I knew that I needed
to like focus on that and like after
being in all of these relationships that
just didn't work out like thank God none
of them wanted to marry me you know and
they took it that far like thank God it
didn't work out because it was a point
it was I'm at a point where I was like
okay this is this is what I've been
missing in my life and this is what I
need to feed you know what I mean kids
do I like it you ever see yourself
having children
um maybe one day like when I'm older in
my 40s women are having kids in their
40s oh yeah my wife at 40 I'd I'd be a
great pregnant 40 year old right now
comedy comedy I'm this is what this is
what I'm gonna do no matter what like
it's just amazing you know when you look
up in San Li and like a dictionary is
doing something over and over again with
the same result you know and I always
think about that ya know with Tommy all
those years that people look at you like
you're [ __ ] insane you're living in
your car you delivering pizza yeah but I
was getting on stage three nights a week
and then afterward I would talk comedy
till 3:00 in the morning at a Denny's or
we would go to a supermarket yeah cold
cuts and just sit outside and talk
family and questions and Booker's and
you know it was just endless with me
yeah like by 94 I went home at night to
read Tommy biography Wow
like that type of [ __ ] somebody sent me
a picture today that blew my [ __ ]
mind one of the guys that helped me out
in the beginning his name was uh George
George McKelvey Jordan McKelvey had
builded Tonight Show like 13 times he
started with you know Johnny Carson went
to 60s and [ __ ] and George McKelvey like
when everybody hated me
George McAfee dug the [ __ ] yeah
like no claw he's too dirty you know we
don't know he's just starting out it was
just really weird that George McHale we
would call me nobody doing this weekend
come open for me
that's could only get your 50 bucks 25
bucks and he was just really good to me
then there was a there's a big-time
manager now in town and I know her she
knows me I'm family you know each other
but I know how from way back in the day
when she was robbing people
oh wow like when she would tell people
you can't do the open mike at this club
until you take my stand of course oh wow
so you would have to pay like you know
yeah three bills for eight weeks of her
course before you got to be picked you
only picked four people a weekend so
your overnight how long are they doing
15 minutes okay so this is how [ __ ]
it was like yeah if you did a class for
eight weeks and you could do 15 minutes
so they're doing a documentary on the
Denver comedy scene and they want me to
do it then when they contacted me the
first time I spoke highly about George
McKelvey and today they sent me just
pranked it
oh wow who's George McHale be standing
with in his book he credited George
McKelvey that's [ __ ] Steve Martin oh
wow nineteen sixties no young he's a
baby look at him
so George no gray hair no white hair
no nothing - baby looks the same that's
pretty [ __ ] crazy
which one's the one another right Wow
Steve can get it so packing I'd never
forget George McKelvey called me one
Sunday night like I was probably feeling
sorry about myself about to do a pound
of blow think of where I am I'm all
because I gotta pay to those days yeah I
would have to run to the gas station to
call people back [ __ ] nightmare oh my
god I can only imagine I'm trying to get
booked back then with beepers and pagers
and beepers
you actually have to keep a calendar
like who walks around how do you
remember your dates I'll never forget a
Booker telling me don't leave me a
message anymore
you have to send me an email Wow on
Monday I totally got [ __ ] then there
was another comedy scene where they
would put gigs up there was a like a guy
who booked rooms oh wow
and he have like eight rooms in Nebraska
and on Monday he would put his available
what clubs were open that week okay and
you have like 10 seconds - oh it was
like that yeah yeah yeah oh yeah you
have ten seconds it's like when you have
a Southwest plane ticket yeah you want
to get a white one yeah but you you wait
ten seconds you're like 860 and you're
like what the [ __ ] Wow who is the
whoever whose wife whose wives are my
buddies at home like this look at that
refresh refresh so is [ __ ] like that you
know I mean there's just so many
different
what about fax machines do you ever have
to fax things you had to fax in your
availability Jesus I remember when I was
first here and I was trying to make the
transition for him okay so I got into
the comedy store I'm working the improv
Jamie doesn't let me work the club but I
do Latino night which is just as good
they would do a street other people yeah
and I [ __ ] just was stuck I didn't
know what to do I had I had like maybe
three clubs that hired me that no paso
find me as a feature act Tribble I think
there was somebody else that hired me so
I went I got a bunch of numbers from
people like at The Comedy Store I would
ask people where you're from and they
would go DC and I go who do I call DC
yeah and then gaming the number DC was
John X Boston was this other guy that
Club 56 and every Monday [ __ ] 9 a.m.
even if I snorted coke till 7:45 at 6
a.m. I would start so they will have the
fax at 9 a.m. and I would fax what you
would do is put like you know wolfy and
then put the whole month of January and
then you know you would put a calendar
and then give me your dates and what was
open but for you to [ __ ] get booked
you had a lie about a date on there oh
yeah I can't do it this weekend you have
to see that you're working on the club
right if you send them an empty calendly
you get a lot so you make sure he didn't
know who that club was or quality same
Wolfson's working that week in June what
do you think of her and if you know I'm
saying it's like your mom catching you
at not at your girlfriend's house you
were out yeah so you had it all and make
up so I took the job selling nuts and
screws oh wow I BA between Hollywood
Boulevard I live right down there and
what's the one on top of Hollywood nuts
Franklin Franklin yeah so what a pizza
place is Franklin and Ivar yeah Franklin
I blog right across feed there's a pizza
place okay
well-known pizza place Joe's pizza I
don't know how it does now used to be
good when they got nachos pizza right no
it's yeah Joe's pizza is maybe a block
two blocks away from added West okay so
there was a place in there you're right
I had to be there at 4:00 in the morning
oh because you have to sell contractors
okay
are these car nuts and screws nuts and
screws will they get the [ __ ] work so
I would you snort coke till three house
yeah next door would close it too I
would keep my car on the back of the
store and just pop the seat back and lay
back I would do a couple lines of coke
bang one out and then [ __ ] head over
with the eyeball and sell screws cats
seven o'clock tinkling
at about 6:00 I'd start [ __ ] facts
and [ __ ] I didn't have a fact
where are you where are you out finding
facts it I was a homeless [ __ ] guy
he's doing more he's saying I got a job
I would make money from seven before
a.m. to six you guys think I'm here I'm
just here to use your fax machine that
was basically out I went to the big
month I was making like a bills a week
so nuts and screws yeah that was and I
would leave a [ __ ] like they would
say after you make minimum you go home
yeah I would make [ __ ] 200 by 6:00
and start faxing at 6:00 a.m. I would
fax every club owner I'd have a notebook
with [ __ ] dates written across it for
checks and what the result was you have
to you're a businessman yeah you're a
CEO yeah so you know you don't want to
call the guy hey Rachel hi Joe Diaz I
want to know if I could work your club
and she's like you just called me last
Monday what did I tell you so you have
to keep records right so I had a
notebook just even then just for who I
contacted what [ __ ] story I told
them in those days they would say send
the tape no tape Wow okay you're not
getting [ __ ] it's a different it's just
different completely different now most
people wouldn't even because the I bet
you half of us wouldn't even be around
if it was like that no no one would even
that was they can't even tie their shoes
some of these people no shower before
they hit the mic you know it was a
different game you had a it was a day
job you think some of these people are
gonna keep my organizational no but you
had a real for our day job Tapia writing
you had a stand and then you had a say
and then you sent those and don't think
you've got work like I didn't say
nothing about getting work that I know
that was endless that was endless that
was endless and then once in a while a
number will come up on your page and he
would be like yo ders Booker mark Cano
was his name and he would go hey Mark
whatever Joe Diaz yeah so you're in
Michigan you know like he
I would put like Joe's comedy club yeah
he would go you're gonna be a Michigan
that week yeah all right give me the
name of three headline is that you've
worked with
let me call around and I'll see if I
could put your essence and then you
wouldn't get it damn and then you
wouldn't get it because that's it was
they wouldn't bounce for you
like no you know now he has to get a
hold of them right you know I'm saying
it all that she's he forgot so you'd
have to call him and say what about that
week in Detroit then he'd go K you know
I need you turns day Friday it's one
night he would put you on the stringer
one-nighters I still remember going from
white [ __ ] Niles like ishm I mean
like the bottom of Michigan all the way
to the [ __ ] the top like no Niles is
on the bottom and ishm I mean is on top
Traverse City like you would stop it
would be like five hours a day of
driving you know like five hours here
then fine but I was there then you
weren't here so it was like a [ __ ]
adventure yeah but that's how it was I
hit took and then I would bother Rachel
for a year Rachel Jody is nothing I'll
call you when I have something yeah send
me a tape who do you work with give me
the name of three references and write
about when you're about to give up the
leap eight walks up the Angels a fool
are you doing next week you want to go
to Jacksonville improv and you're like
I've been bugging them for a [ __ ]
year but like I've been bugging them for
a year they keep telling me no and now
you make one phone call and I'm
featuring I got my own hotel room I
don't have to sleep on the floor
I'd like to see what they can about this
you like blown the [ __ ] away that's
that's the angle like they used to be a
catch a rising star in Vegas you're too
young for that that was in the excalibur
you're too young for that wait but I was
I was you were young girl yeah I was
alive no you were a lot oh yeah that's a
club it was no more the hotel was the
excalibur yeah and it has
sword theme yeah it's so light I mean I
saw they're still there were these
polymers so they're it's still very
callable upstairs this catch a rising
star okay for a [ __ ] year and a half
it's a club you don't have it you should
be a chain okay it was in it just see if
the one in Jersey still open Wow
it was Jersey like in [ __ ] of course
it was New Jersey in Vegas Princeton no
Princeton
Vegas and Reno what the glass factory
Reno yeah Oh like I've heard of this yes
brand before that you rising star was in
Reno and that was that was Wow it was a
[ __ ] that was a how was that room at the
Excalibur the catch a rising star room
it was one before you were saying that
you worked yeah a week with Dahmer right
now how is in love with Tommy at this
point I had been doing comedy I say
roughly ten years I had opened up Rogan
and see I'd open up a for Rodriguez I'd
opened up for people and I got a week or
what all the [ __ ] I tortured catch a
rising star [ __ ] year and a half and
I called my mother every Monday I don't
know one you know my [ __ ] oh yeah my
[ __ ] is the real deal Sunday nights I
would get home and send headshots of
casting people every Monday was my
headshot day so they would get him on
Wednesday and I would send tickets to
The Comedy Store free passes to the
Comedy Store and the improv
that's cool this is what I thought I
remember going in for an audition for
Sheila Jaffe one time and I ate a bag
like I was in there all go home like a
robe on it was like a boxing coach and
[ __ ] and I just ate a bag of dicks and
she goes thank you for coming in and the
assistant goes and Sheila Jaffe this was
just oh yeah hold on I have something
for you she gave me back a stack of
headshots
Oh I mean 30 headshots with resumes tons
of free passes from the Comedy Store
she gave it to you back yeah she's a
golem believe this what a [ __ ]
no no she ended up booking me okay
perfect me love her I was like no it's
just that was the job yeah that's how
much the job entailed yeah no she's not
a [ __ ] now you got a lot yeah now all
you have to do is click the button on
your computer
oh wow every Monday oh yeah it's so
different I would wake up a male [ __ ]
Tuesday was drop off [ __ ] so every day I
had a different job right now it's just
you can just email 50 people and mine
before 9/11 you can walk into the studio
oh that I could walk into for 9/11 they
took they took studio actually one at 11
I go to Fox to the gate and go I want to
drop off a package of Rachel water Wow
they go just Park over there make it
quick you do they make you take off your
shoes no no this is this was like it was
very open Fox what a fox when I want a
drop of package for Christian Kaplan
they would go park there run upstairs
don't take more than three minutes
oh wow good run up drop the package up
see the assistant the assistant will
look at you because they're looking for
a person like you right you just don't
have an agent or your agents of schmuck
I would drop off my own [ __ ] on Tuesday
so Tuesday was drop off day that agent
you want to find way they won't sign you
every Tuesday got a new package at his
door it was it was they couldn't get rid
of you know it was $29 for a hundred
headshots I'm coming off I'm coming all
day long I would buy three hundred at
one shot every ten days amazing and then
when I got the agent I'd show up every
other week with 20 more headshots resume
they don't forget me I love that
relentlessness if that's that's this
what this all is about yeah this is that
love that you have yeah that's what and
you're not going anywhere
you don't read this in a book no you
don't read this in a book no books gonna
teach you this this is you know what
there was a kid here Cory mo got to half
million dollar deals real good-lookin
black dude very funny
he went back to Atlanta to raise his
kids cuz the show didn't get picked up
but he had this thing Mondays he would
write poetry wasn't a poet
it wasn't no bullet but that was part of
his exercise Tuesday he would write
comedy Wednesday he would write a script
about underwater fishing Thursday he
would write [ __ ] comedy and Friday
would write music wasn't a musician but
he said he wanted to explore all the
different things like his mind go to all
these different places that's the level
I love oh [ __ ] that you know when I
hooked up with your boy Philippe you
know how would meet weave SAP I won't
get acting class yeah
me Philippe Silent Bob Sebastian Cetina
we would give ourselves our own homework
assignments yeah we said [ __ ] paying
$300 and we critique each other I asked
him that's smart ask I will ask him yeah
and then we go from there go to a weed
store and [ __ ] stock up on edibles
the guy was a baker at a Beverly Hills
place and he quit his job baking to open
up a weed store and he would bake edible
so not like regular like other you would
get a hundred pounds right like you know
victory fudge with three lemons and you
be pop pop one of them but next time
what are you gonna see them again what
are you opening fan august in you see a
person could knock that have to get
carried to a car that's what happened
and his legs got a drag on the no way
and they were walking them into a car
one at one morning acting class we
started popping edibles and [ __ ] that's
whenever right stress between oh man
coconuts you [ __ ] this guy would make a
coconut three [ __ ] layer cake with
coconut in the middle with THC in that
[ __ ] and he didn't know you go to his
house they'd just be squeezing green
[ __ ] or the coconut cake was green for
starters you thought it was Saint
Patty's Day always chocolate was green
saying everything he had was [ __ ]
that is amazing and he can end Roderigo
smokes heavy weed so I can only imagine
we're gone what talking 2000 this is
back in the day we were on guinea pigs
with them with the edibles looking for
this is when Philippe had Wednesday
night no coyotes oh wow I love that
place
have you been there of course they still
do comedy then uh-uh
I better eat there oh you've been there
to eat yeah no oh you're thinking about
[ __ ] in the hood oh no I'm not I'm
talking about a different but I'm like
el coyote a place where they changed the
name four times in one year oh my god it
was a drug bar really [ __ ] wait was it a
it was just a bar Felipe dated the twins
fool oh I wanna [ __ ] the sister hell I
don't know which one it was
stop that's amazing oh my god yeah they
had so they give you a change in the
name four times a year every four times
E twins ever find out about each other
the twins worked that together hot both
of them were 12 Wow every Mexican chick
that worked in there have it'd be a
[ __ ] 12 you're not gonna find any of
those [ __ ] in the Tennessee Senate
that's what I would pull them either
right through the tension so they would
go down and go you get those four
Bedford boys they're on fire and they
take them at a coyote and Wednesday
nights was comedy night got 40 bucks in
a burrito oh that's yeah yeah oh my god
you would need all day like you were
that broke that you were sweating that
burrito open I'm trying to get it's open
it's under a different name now oh of
course it's under a different means 40th
Lane you know I could tell you if I if I
tell you the names today that has been
there his open mic is like just like
feature acts you would [ __ ] die
that's so funny
what about that thing you posted I think
was a day or two ago on Twitter that
scheduled the laugh stop that was pretty
crazy oh my god just like it was you Tom
Rhodes Rogen Fitzsimmons and a couple
that was a big name gotta be 2001 2002
that's pretty good damn it's such a
[ __ ] journey guys that's must be
probably good like I can't whenever I
see stuff like that I'm like what if I
see Rachel in 20 years and and we were
on the fourth wall list together and
like that's it it's pretty cool that's
what I'm saying
it's like I see pictures of people of
you guys from the past and it's like wow
this is a moment in time and like Josh
wolf posted one a year ago yeah open mic
list me and Darrin caught it you know
like you know this is Dave Chappelle
before yeah Dave Chappelle you know I'm
not good I'm not gonna save any stuff
like that I don't you got to I might
never have setlist no I don't really say
I take pictures occasionally but very
right now that was never something that
I I just don't even think about it I got
a folder of my comedy setlist yeah a
folder at the bottom might draw on one
side and setlist and the other side is
call sheets Wow
all the big call sheets and the little
miniature ones they put in your [ __ ]
agreement Wow yeah you gotta see those
I mean you don't have to know I did it
would be cool it's your own little
museum I like I have my like comedy
notebooks like that I've that I've
already like I'm saving them like I'm
it's an honor to like fill another
another you know what I mean wait yeah
like what an insane person 10 years from
now you go the sort that I did this
material in front of all the biggest
agents yeah like material I chose to do
how embarassing have that set set list
like you'll have your your diary for the
day and that night before you go out
you'll have like the set list before you
know APA APA was huge when I got and
then his showcase one night I found it
setlist
about four years ago Wow and I wanted to
run into a wall headfirst run into a
wall at first like the topics would just
Arend this like I remember like a topic
and a joke just to run this like you
look at that [ __ ] and go I'm gonna be
regretting I'm gonna there's gonna come
a day where I'm gonna regret all the
eating ass material I've done yeah not
the eating ass the material right listen
man you know it's a part of my say it
you know you say it onstage you know
that's why comedy makes you so
vulnerable
yeah and say this [ __ ] and you don't
look back and guess what what I wasn't
saying this [ __ ] I didn't have a career
yeah
so when I was talking about all that
goofy [ __ ] the first thing is a comedy
and I thought I was making strides but I
was a regular at the store I was a
regular at The Improv
he was just a guy crack and joke okay
you want just a [ __ ] that got good at
cracking rehearse jokes right it's not
till you go into that second layer the
epidermal and start saying let me tell
you what I did and then bring it to life
with a joke and make them screech a
little first right and then go oh we
didn't know you were going that yeah you
know this is the first 10 years you just
don't knock-knock jokes
yeah just a [ __ ] wedding photographer
mitzvah deejay it's prickly I did a show
with hey-zeus Trejo last night and I
like even if I last night wasn't my best
set but even seeing people do well but
then seeing someone like him there's
just a different level of laughter and
the laughter is more consistent and it's
just it's like it's like seeing like a
superhero it's pretty crazy to see
someone who's doing what you want to do
and doing it like such a higher level so
ensuring yeah you never want to be the
best like for me I don't ever want to be
the best comic in there look in the rim
don't I mean like I want well you do but
you don't
yeah but like I always hope that there's
someone around that I can learn
something from well you know not even if
it's not though you know whatever
like we said on Mondays podcast a me
years ago watch
rogon at the Union at the Union it was a
bar next to across the street from
Miyagi which nobody knows I'm talking
about right now it's a course change the
name three times across the street of
you go 30 yards I forget what it is now
it was the Union and I had been working
with Joe for about three is at the time
and I saw him gave him great sets at the
store but that night he was on pinpoint
and every young comic in the room from I
mean I can't even tell Nick DiPaolo was
there that night like everybody looked
at him except for maybe Nick DiPaolo and
a couple other guys that were in the
room higher level guys all that whole
core I was with like I wasn't jealous of
general but I knew that if I did the
work that was gonna be me in 10 years
yeah but that's all that's all yeah
there was no like a it was like wow and
then both sometimes you catch
performances
that'll doubt you right you go home and
go it's time to get out as it recruiter
I'll never get that good the first time
I saw Stan opened 96 like I had I knew
Doug but I've worked with Doug in 92 and
91 and 96 he was a complete different
animal that I went like I had a gig that
sad there so I'm gonna Friday and that
sad that I can't Wow like that's how
shocking and how good precise time yeah
free was the word right I didn't
understand that you had to be free he
was free he was out of the cage
there was no holds barred it was Stan
how [ __ ] coming at you people walking
people crapping their purses and paying
their bills and he's yelling at him as
they're walking out go [ __ ] yourself
where you going I got an abortion joke
you gotta hear you know like just
tormenting them as they walked out and
you're sitting there going I just want
people to sit laughs yeah what point are
you happy
people walked out yeah he had flipped it
around there was another comic in
Seattle but that was his thing to go on
stage and grow there was two of them a
girl and a guy that they we're gonna
make him walk well you you won the war
but you lost a battle
ray Stanhope was doing a little
differently
Stanhope was one of the war and the back
because as he was throwing you out
people were laughing yeah he was
throwing you out well wait you're not
gonna hear my pipbuck joke don't go no
way yeah and the woman would be I've
never you know I get was [ __ ] nuts
like what you know I heard what he was
doing down here then he would do sets at
the improv and just disrupt the show
like the show would be [ __ ] disrupted
like all these neat comics will go up
with their notebooks and their [ __ ]
squirmy [ __ ] and they would get nothing
because what they had just seen was so
surreal the first time I saw Stanhope I
cracked but then the second type of
performance I saw was broke and at the
Union I go wait a second two years ago I
wasn't even I was [ __ ] yeah
delivering pizza so we've been Chinese
food now I'm closer to this guy and I'm
able to see this so that means I'm
making pop right exactly you know you're
making progress I know that that'll be
me and they is yeah if I get on stage
every [ __ ] day exactly when you're at
that point and you say I'm getting on
stage every day you [ __ ] mean yeah
I'm talking about hi this is mom I'm
coming too busy and you're like I hope
not cuz I got a weekend up and Fresno
yeah I mean it gets to that point yeah
well you like options leave my best
friend's wedding yeah no I I was in
Vegas that's to disappear I went my best
friend is the one wedding I wanted to
actually be at I got to be there for an
hour that's a distance I saw them smooch
I saw them I ate some I ate a plate of
food I did I took the food and I dipped
I wanted to be there more than anything
but I was like I I want to be on stage
more than anything else you know but
this is what I really want and I get it
the first clicks the discipline becomes
intense yeah the discipline that you
have to put on yourself like the word
vacation is disappears yeah the word day
off disappears the word wedding
disappears like there's so many things
that just disappeared relationships
relationships disappear you really want
to do what you want to do that person
will leave on their own yeah cuz they
know they can't compete I can't compete
yes
guess what my friends and I are having
this thing like oh as we do it 11 yeah
exactly meaning but you can't be doing
comedy has to be that one night off when
you do comic stores open 365 days a week
what does that tell you but yesterday
you did comics and you did the pizza
placing he was so funny
that was yesterday I gotta earn my
stripes today yeah and you get this
weird discipline day and I mean I got to
the point and you get Joshua next time
you go up there you're Josh
all those years were you having parties
in that way that Jodie is over shell
that was yeah I always had a spot to do
I don't know what are you talking about
there was a girl broke up with me
because she was into that [ __ ] you know
my brothers are coming up to visit me
I'm gonna do with me no that's god none
that syour brothers no I got no brothers
my sisters in Cuba that [ __ ] comes over
she's gonna get the same tree yeah I
don't know what you're talking about
that's why I love people who take comics
and they're not in the business see his
comedians you can't be with no economy
why because it's not gonna work how do
you know I've been here for 22 years but
if there are people there are comics you
do it does work out why take the chance
okay why take the chance why take the
chance
what is what happens what happens if you
start laying Dana lead today okay you
only fall in love okay good again okay
and now you start booking yes okay take
this more to
with you know so the first six months
they'll be fun you take this more to
done with it after that obviously you
want to be on yourself on the weekends
you want to go do your own three things
guess who's gonna get mad boom
what are you gonna get mad Lee what
happens if you date this [ __ ] more to
death hey I know you both showcase for
Montreal right but you get picked are
you gonna tell me you got picked and
those [ __ ] ass is gonna stay home oh
that's what she's gonna want to do well
I'll just come with you I don't want you
can't come with me I wanna drive it I
don't even think that like for me I feel
like it could work if no it couldn't
well see like never gonna work I even
notice a little bit of what you're
talking I just friends just like comedy
friends wanted to come to gigs and you
know I just stand up as you in a wall no
microphone if you want to join the band
join the beat go to reunite with [ __ ]
uh SWV is something he's a white chick
that's the bad mistake that you know you
don't know who do you date if you're a
comic non-college you de dum non-comic
non cut then you have to train them from
what about Natasha and mo che there's a
couple that's what about Segura and like
I said there's one of the million but
the percentage what about rich vos and
Bonnie McFarlane the percentages are
very low yeah but III get what about the
agent from ICM and other the chick
wizard career too late what about ralfie
and Lana I agree with you for the most
most off number two both all three of
those women you names yeah a very very
very very very comfortable in one their
sexuality and two and in their skin okay
those three women are not needy Tom
Segura kicked on circle his wife will
bitch-slap you quicker than our slap oh
yeah body McFarland were you when the
[ __ ] head with a shovel quicker than
whatever and the other crazy [ __ ] you
talked about who else Natasha Natasha
Leggero
and I get it I come from probably let me
ask you this how many comics Natasha
Leggero date before she settled on Moshe
kasher probably a lot okay yeah yeah so
now you got 20 more lines you walk into
a club oh look at that Lisa I used to
[ __ ] her up the ass and put it on Wow
okay I agree with you come no no I would
never listen I don't think people should
[ __ ] where they eat I'm very much
against that however I think in those
Kate those are the cases where I'm like
I do like seeing those people together
because they're perfect for each other
because they are comfortable with
exactly who they both are and there's no
competition but I don't think every
comic should be out here dating kind if
you are dating economic I don't
necessarily once you decide to move in
Woodleigh you gotta say your rules yeah
boundaries your rule yeah same thing
what happens when you did it civilian
yeah because let me tell you something I
love you that you're beautiful you're
beautiful I want to marry you right
should we get married
what does Joey do Joey is a successful
contract they make seven figures a year
six figures a year yeah he's very
comfortable on who he is we start
humping the [ __ ] awesome you spit out
a little [ __ ] wolfy and you know what
I'm not the [ __ ] nanny type yeah so
you're gonna go on the road with Dave
Chappelle and yeah Joe Rogan and I'm
gonna stay at home and watch the kid mr.
nanny you got a better chance for
[ __ ] dying somewhere along the line
it's just I like women who meet I love
dumb [ __ ] we'll hook up with comics
are you like watching it oh I love it
yeah I've seen that one 300,000 oh man I
feel like you don't want reality TV i
watch reality TV i watch life okay i
watch life and use people as guinea pigs
in my own little private shower
I would pay to watch the show look at
you I look at you and we and I'll be
happy if you guys do last but I'll have
doubts about different things just I'll
just watch it yeah I won't but then I'll
just give if you got into Montreal I
would and I didn't it would make me so
happy because in my mind we got into
Montreal okay she's gonna tackle no I
have a gig that weekend so you go off
and do Montreal I'm gonna be over here
doing my gig and also if we've been
doing it a lot longer than I have so for
me
in that sense I got a respect that you
know what I mean like Blackwall see I
see what you're saying but even me
myself I can be a jealous person
I could I could see myself I'd date you
that means now I gotta take you on the
road with me no we're not married to be
on the [ __ ] road together - or how
about we Donnie in [ __ ] memory books
that show tonight chair give me that
buggers number like that you're not but
I think a lot of people are I'm very I'm
I'm I my first year of comedy was very
much as much as it was getting on stage
and like writing and and learning that
and whatever it was also the mental side
of it and having to deal with those
emotions of jealousy and worrying about
what other people are doing and really I
got to a place in my comedy where I'm
like okay I am confident that like in my
material and who I am and like my like
that I know that I'm funny and that I'm
in this journey this is a journey for me
it's not like a rush
I'm not everything that I've gotten has
come to me at the right time and when
I've felt like I deserved I'm not one
out here like begging for spots if I
don't have a spot
I met mics I'm writing every day I'm
getting better as a comic and I feel
like I've I've had to come to terms with
that even with friends because a lot of
my friends were getting stuff you know
and I was watching that in the first
year at comedy but you know what I
started to get stuff and it didn't stop
I started to get
a lot of stuff and I started to and I
was like their success was my motivation
you know what I mean and I just I'm not
ever coming from a place of jealousy I
always come from a place of gratefulness
and gratitude that I'm even just here so
like I think it takes the right kind of
people one to be in comedy and two to
date comics to comics it's never I don't
but it's comedy is not for everyone in
dating comics is not for everyone
nor should it be record everyone if I
dated or when you say dated I [ __ ]
around with manual comic side part time
data one comic where any of them
enjoyable for you it got uncomfortable
at what point what you put in their ass
no I didn't get to that part it would
even take somebody home they're a good
piece of ass you having a good time but
then they do one little thing that blows
off the [ __ ] whole night if they
would have done on the third night it
wouldn't bother as much as the first
night okay
like the four comic chicks I slept with
while looking for something what do you
mean they were looking for help it's oh
oh oh I see like from you for what their
careers oh oh so they're in that part of
my career that remember this is this is
this is no is it the store right this is
girls that would see me at the store
right and go you didn't think they loved
you for you no no no no this is my oh no
no I'm being cynical I'm not saying that
yeah I'd better hurry
yeah blonde girl like kinda I dated her
I really liked her yeah and I kept it as
as as detailed as I could
but I couldn't take it about six weeks
on the road without uh sucking my dick
oh brother what because she was that
much fun yeah we did code together so
was a blast like a lighter [ __ ] on
[ __ ] ha ha ha
I'm those lights on those off nights
yeah instead of paying for the hotel
room myself I'm sharing it with another
comic and that's what I didn't like oh
you didn't like that I got back to that
I was done okay I still liked her and I
still messed around with her but our
road work we've done Wow do you did you
run into anything with cuz you you met
you met your wife I had when she was
working at the store not she wasn't a
comic but was there any weirdness there
with her being at your work or with her
knowing with other comics knowing that
you worked there they were happily I
kept it under a hat for you yeah can I
tell you something my parents are it
makes me a rare example of people who
work well yeah that could stay yeah
ran a business together and have a
successful mayor together and these are
these are not this is not recommended
either for these people to be dating
clothes and each of us comedian no but
they were politicians and let me tell
you there is just as much competition to
see your significant mother I get the
competition part as comics that
everybody chooses this career chair for
a reason
so there's a little bit of a comedian
there's a little bit of we're not
completely on our game okay your phone's
antia we're not completely out again
after I was thoroughly I learned that
like where you are now you start
learning more about your relationships
and where you are so I learned the one
thing you know what Rachel's [ __ ]
beautiful I can't date Rachel she's
psycho she's no [ __ ] pothead like me
uh-huh that means every [ __ ] day me
and Rachel gonna smoke a pound of
[ __ ] weed and we're gonna go into
debt together no we're not I'm gonna be
up working out what I'm wrong about the
catching that might be you enough
and I'm a cocaine head that's it work
but if you're a cocaine and I look okay
in it it's not gonna work okay
like after I was dirty I saw the figure
that so you gotta just find someone who
does so there's a younger me yeah yeah
you know it's a yin and a yang I'm
really I feel like Rick Messina when he
told that girl that comedy doesn't work
on uh if you're over 28 I should have
never said that just in the years I've
been here I saw a lot more people break
up comics and a lot more stay together
yeah I saw I mean a lot yeah you know
when you're doing Kali four or five
years and you're into it like a girl
like you you're dealing with comedians
seven nights a week I bump into you we
go to Demi so we go back to the house
you smoke a joint
you come out with pajamas on something
happens why are you letting my secrets
out little by little we try it's
happened a thousand times you know but
it ends kind of weird and no I got us
like met seashore
let's say you and I dated and we were
both at the store if we broke up
perhaps the two years and Mitzie found
out now she would make you follow me oh
my god everybody and I would make or me
follow you every night so she was a
divorce you guys have to work together
she would make no weirdness no no
there's difference between working
together you're the MC and I'm the
headline I like but when you gotta bring
me up and shake my hand even though you
left me Philippe Oh God okay you you
left me
triangle carefully literally so now I
gotta go follow you even though I want
to spit in your face or I left you for
your sister dan would you want to bring
me up without my [ __ ] faith that's a
complete different emotion she what's
happened that's probably great for the
stage though oh so inspiring you know
because what are you not gonna shake my
hand
yeah no I are you gonna go up on stage
and say this next guy coming to the
stage [ __ ] my sister stole my car and
cheated on me and gave me [ __ ]
chlamydia
my sister the climatic and we're getting
married next week we don't actually be
kind of funny would you say that no you
have to say this next guy love I've seen
him on a trio and I've seen him on
Showtime and Comedy Central
he's one of our all-time favorites keep
it going you know and you got to say
this while your hearts breaking he's
going off the assistant that builds
that's called to discipline hmm this I'm
ready for this no this is Leigh are you
ready to [ __ ] my sister bring me up on
stage sure this is just like the Japs
did you know there's a there's a
discipline number one the Japs and you
[ __ ] up what do you do and [ __ ] is
that hari-kari
it's a discipline how you [ __ ] up you
cut your thumb off yeah we're not
cutting thumbs often hear nothing but
you have to run this CEO of your calmly
like it's yeah it's a discipline I don't
give a [ __ ] if the period is gushing out
of my [ __ ] I got a minute spot that's
yeah these are all the things that you
know I don't care if I'm sick you know
they just when you get into that love of
it it's just this discipline that's like
but I feel like it kind of is like all
right Carl I just you know in the way
like if you go onstage and have a bat
I'll get feels like you're stabbing
yourself and you kind of I feel like
maybe the point of high cards so you
learn from it and hopefully you learn
from you make like you're like I'm not
gonna make that mistake again on stage
in some way I think it's simpler no you
make that mistake getting it to see if
it was even a mistake okay okay I never
thought about that make a mistake again
on stage to see if it was even a mistake
maybe they were just norian that was def
you didn't get the Mack you know maybe
they were audience that doesn't like
[ __ ] sucking and [ __ ] you didn't
get the memo you know yeah
I'm sorry returning your podcast into a
comedy class Oh know that I'm learning
so much
oh no so interesting oh thank you so who
do you write for now I know you're right
do you I'm I'm not I mean I've written
for publications I've written for high
times Mary Jane vice Playboy right now I
just work in do marketing during the day
for the wheat industry and comedy at
night and when you say wheat industry
what do you I were to sign your paycheck
uh bud feed push queen I shoot for a
bunch of brands I yeah I do social media
marketing so I get a lot of work in the
wheat industry just you smoking
talking about that price well i did i do
shoots i am part of a youtube channel
where we film videos we have like 70,000
subscribers all about we'd kind of from
an educational base standpoint with a
little bit of humor and then I write for
publications I do social media marketing
for brands and companies I run ads on my
account
so yeah I just I try to limit pretty
much making a living off the week um not
fully a living like I'm between weed and
comedy that's what I make my living off
of now you also said in an interview
that get to know the weed plant and keep
it original yeah if you want to get into
the business yeah what did you mean by
that way well you don't know the plan
yeah for me I just see a lot of people
who are getting into the industry I mean
everyone has their intentions of getting
into weed but I just think that you need
to really I don't like seeing people who
get into the industry and don't have a
relationship with the plant because for
me it's a medicine and it's yeah and
it's I feel like it's like you're taking
advantage of something and of people who
you know this is a medicine this is
something that's special to us it's
healing and it's becoming so corporate
and that's the side of it that like when
we voted for legalization that a lot of
people warned us about that this is what
it would turn into and you know over
time I think things will change
but you're seeing so many different
kinds of people trying to get into the
industry and I get asked this question a
lot of like how do I get in
what's the best way because I've been
smoking for two weeks
yeah that I saw in the very beginning I
saw a lot of fakes faking the funk well
and so for me it's just like well you
know one get to know the plant from an
authentic standpoint fine why you love
this plant
what is it that attracts you to the to
the plant and then for me be original
like whatever you're doing whatever
you're producing whatever you're putting
out there whether it's marketing or
you're trying to do a brand or you're
trying to do a grow like be original be
authentic like find a way to add not
take away from whatever is out there I
guess you know you brought a blunt I did
and we slowed it before the show yes if
this was three years ago right now we'd
be on our fiftieth bomb mm anibal's yeah
I had to cut that out for two reasons
number one I listened to the podcast I'm
gonna put in our shitty time and the
other problem was that I was attracting
the wrong kind of audience oh yes okay I
didn't want the audio I didn't want to
have a wider audience I smoked you know
a [ __ ] eighth every two days of 25%
and over THC okay
and I have a bomb I got this one at a
time okay well I wake up two three three
before I go lift three when I come back
amazing two one a dream before I got a
pretty smokin eight an hour do you
really I mean I can go through a Nathan
little day yeah I can I could do one a
day
the bong slows me down yeah I should
probably do that the bong I do the bong
because it's a bigger hit and I get them
more from my bank yeah when I smoke now
number two I can't smoke the same weed
every day
yeah so when I go to the weed store I
gotta buy for weeds indicate what day
time we did nighttime weed I'm gonna be
the guy okay for sure
if it's if it's a holiday if it's a
high-bred that in the Kodama native
and the percentages I'll go with that
sativas just do not work yeah does maybe
wanted to sativas that put me in a
different state but the rest of them
don't do dick to me yeah I feel that I'm
an indica dominant in one of your
interviews or one of your YouTube videos
I saw that you had ADHD and then you
were bipolar when you were 12 you know
between you and me I don't know what
half that [ __ ] is no I wanna [ __ ]
know yeah but I know do know that I had
the same thing I didn't get I just knew
from the first time I smoked weed not
alcohol that's not coke not even pills
none of that [ __ ] as far as we concerned
something happened to me yeah
if you know this I'm not a big weed and
a group type of guy right you won't see
me at weed functions yeah I'm not that's
not my bag for me I do it like the
[ __ ] Indians it's uh it's uh it's
ritually yeah you know what is it very
much it's a ritual firmly a personal
ritual yeah I can't lie the end a lot of
people gonna hate on me for this I don't
really do wanna okay it's a ritual form
yeah I like ripping the paper and then
gluing it together don't letting it dry
and while it dries I'm breaking up my
bud and I'm listening to it music and
then I put it together like I wrote two
joints and put him like singing go to
him when I'm on the road and I've smoked
him before the first job before the
second show I really don't want to smoke
with nobody yeah it's my own personal
little ritual totally you know if I know
that you're gonna be they bring seven
joints so I could give you one your own
joint it's just in case you blew a
[ __ ] [ __ ] terrorist last night
yeah I don't have to have terrorist
germs of my long of age and orange I'm
saying when I was a kid I would get sick
when I smoked in circles oh wow I would
get really sad whatever so for me I
never for me it was not about I think
that one this week thing and you and I
both know this we won't mention no names
I think a lot of people got on the weed
boat to sell tickets enter yeah make
people think they were cool
whatever and they the way that guy like
me yeah because like you I've been
hitting this since I was 12 right and I
think for even well I think a comedy
when I think of a comedic mind and I
think of a drunk there's no better drug
yeah you know this morning when I got
back from acupuncture I had [ __ ]
right before I came he had a right a
little bit I did four or five bong hits
loosen the wings young man can the dry
ginger elf diet and I put leave my cell
phone the other room I go on the living
room because I didn't have a chance to
go get caught you know I have you with
that and it's all part of my ritual I
love that if I could I don't like
smoking while I write I like to smoke
leave the bond and the other one and
then I write and then get up an hour
later and go refuel yes I find that's a
discipline get up move around and go
smoke again in another room the the
common thing that I hear from people
about waiting hi is that it'll seem
funny in the moment but then it actually
isn't
have you guys trained yourself to write
high or do you find the same thing about
writing funny of it
it's about relaxing if you read the
Stephen King book on writing it's not
about writing a whole page it's about
sitting there for now okay it's about
you I'm gonna have to read that getting
up going somewhere sitting there facing
the Sun or against the Sun if you read
his book yes it's a certain way towards
the Sun ha Steven Spielberg Jane Prince
Stephen King Prince of [ __ ] darkness
yeah I wrote Cujo has to sit a certain
way in a room facing the Sun and he
plays music while he writes and he locks
the door so nobody to come in I don't
like my wife coming in the room but I'm
[ __ ] right patty oh that's why I go
to like a coffee shop and I sit in the
same place the coffee shops nobody could
come up behind me ah you know I like all
these little rich awesome rituals yeah
marijuana for me has always been a
ritual you know I get up I drink coffee
I pop a nicotine gum I brushed my teeth
done I hit that pipe of death about 40
minutes in by [ __ ] a the
I'm starving now I can leave my two eggs
making what time do you it when you wake
up um I mean honestly every day is
different I wake and bake pretty much
every single day different ways I've
been on blunts lately which is probably
not the healthiest but I just love that
little bit of today I like if we piloted
I love it blunt in a coffee I go and I
work out sometimes I'll wait to smoke
until after I work out because I like to
think of it as a reward you know it's my
wine down and definitely when I'm
writing and even like on before I get up
on stage like Felipe when a you know
we're chief and right until the moment
we get walk on stage and I had some of
my best sets you know high as [ __ ] and
likes I'm just calm where I can like be
myself and like some stuff like maybe a
joke will just come out I'll write it on
stage but me the reefer removes the
safety net yeah I'm [ __ ] Johnny will
Linda let me tell Linda this is your
chance to be what Johnny will endure
smoke this this is another discipline
focus and go onstage deliver the
audience will read that you're high yeah
and they give you brownie points they
give you points so if there's a learning
curve mm-hmm you know when you're
drinking you don't get that learning
curve that's yeah when you're smoking
you get that little curve from the
audience and if you are funny and they
know you stoner you start giggling
they're taking a ride with you yeah you
suck them into your [ __ ] right you
suck them into you you know you really
think I don't do edibles before stage
yeah but I will smoke pot like oh yeah
because like I told my wife the other
day I go this is why I don't like the
word sobriety because you're always
living on a [ __ ] what I can't I can't
I can't
yeah it's like the opposite of improv
marijuana keeps me knowing that I'm
dirty yeah there is something wrong or
real you know I've always I've always
dreamt of giving up coke and alcohol and
pills and all that [ __ ]
marijuana it's never even crossed
[ __ ] mine like I will smoke too they
bury me unless I lose a long or
oh boy I'm the same way pump was it hard
for you in New York or did you be able
to bring enough for the entire month I'm
gonna find weed in New York I brought
[ __ ] two pounds away with me back
there when I was there for three weeks
yeah I have eight different types of
weed your back yeah you don't care
anymore 28 ounces I brought two I bring
a budget bag he's different in the
boxing glove now you have two bags so
they lose one you got weed oh yeah
that's my steep lap near bag has
something you do them all in different
places yeah I don't rate that don't work
bring your bag of apes and I go I'd have
taken them in time just because you gave
them to me no but they don't the vapes
do something to me them in the way that
I'm spitting up the next couple days
yeah where do you see marijuana go in
the future do you see TV shows but I've
watched Bon Appetit another honest I
mean III saw a bus today that the whole
rap of the bus was a CBD advertisement
so it's going mainstream like it's it's
gonna be huge I think there's gonna be
maybe even a weed Channel I wouldn't be
surprised that there was a TV network or
if it all just went online it's really
just when mainstream advertising and the
people like that are willing to put
their dollars behind you know cannabis
content on a mainstream level like
what's like Coke or like Pepsi is gonna
be the first one to like back or sponsor
something like that we're really just
kind of waiting and I think honestly
what if it goes federal that's when
we'll really start to see it on a
different level you know all over the
place it's pretty I don't know I think
it was I don't know if we're both
friends with on Facebook but yesterday
someone posted a picture that some CBD
company had a good time you know what
Times Square look they'll have like
eight different advertisements on the
same company it was a CBD company yeah I
mean it's a future it's everywhere it's
in our Walgreens that they're selling
CBD at Sephora it's my friend has a cush
queen is that Urban Outfitters
now it's a CBD THC bath bombs I'll bring
you some
for you your wife if you guys take baths
for you me I'm a shower yeah okay okay
but I'll break open the same dirt I
don't know maybe your wife maybe I don't
know what you women I think a bath I
work well if I gotta go
how dick once its flow once I see that I
go floating in the [ __ ] bubble so why
are you just wait to jerk off because
drip off on the water yeah yeah
it'll be nice at the bath bomb where do
you see your career going in that six
months in the next six months
oh I'm what do you want to do this I
just continue to hustle writing I signed
an NDA for some stuff that I'm pretty
excited for so I have some things I shot
my first pilot a couple weeks ago so it
was for a comedy for E and it was a game
show that had all female comics on it
that was about pop culture called
material girls so I'm starting to like
I'm open I mean I got my plans are to
learn and to grow and to just be funnier
than the day before and that's like I'm
open you take an acting class I'm second
city really good for you yeah so you
really making this work oh this is my
life this is what I'm doing you have a
roommate nope I live alone
my ex-boyfriend I used to live with one
of my boyfriend's but I no longer live
with them good for you yeah well hope
you stay single for a while it seems
like the kiss of death
oh man so fun I am you're going you know
what right now you're funny and you're
going places where I add that extra
stress I mean I'm not i I'm I'm never
looking for that I'm I know what I want
out of this life I want to stand up as
my main love stand up is my like I'm
married to stand up you know and that's
what I'm gonna be doing to the day I
can't walk anymore
onstage and then I'll roll myself but um
you know I I don't like to plan my like
I have it I hope for the best you know I
just I just focus on what's right in
front of me how can people find you
Facebook Twitter Instagram at Wolfie
comedy and if they like weed humor or
weed content Facebook Twitter Instagram
at Wolfie memes and then my podcast on
stitcher iTunes and Spotify chronic
relief with Rachel Wolfson and I'd love
to have you both on where's your what's
the website where they could get you
date some like that um I don't really
post dates on a website cuz I'm just you
know lazy when it comes to that but my I
do post my dates and my shows on my
Instagram I just think that's where a
lot of my people follow me I know I have
a publicist yeah I recently published
this wanted to be my publicist so I
that's what I'm saying I I I have a lot
of good things I'm in a good place you
know life is happening and I'm just
riding the wave well I've been watching
you about nine months and I could tell
you a hustler thank you you're not
looking for any handouts no never Felipe
speaks very highly of your honor
everybody'll have met her spec spoken
where they've asked me if I if I knowing
you and I don't know but this is the
first time it's great to meet you thank
you you're prettier in person
oh wow the photographs thank you you're
always welcome on the show I love you
guys so where can they find you little
stony ass oh yeah at wilfy comedy that's
where they can find me well and I just
started calling you Wolfie I love it I
love your name I love it it looked like
a wolfies thank you so yeah any time you
want to come again always fair thank you
for having me and I want to thank you
[ __ ] for always supporting us
do not forget the only date I got is the
Lincoln [ __ ] Theatre in DC
August 9th
tickets are moving I'm sorry the more
guys are sold out I can't [ __ ] yes this
sold-out Bell because my family's going
I can add a second show but we just put
tickets up with the stress factory for
October so knock yourself out you want
to go to New Brunswick is there besides
that I want to talk to you guys real
quick and then you go on and enjoy
[ __ ] weekend alright number one
listen we would we wouldn't be a park as
well you guys but he also wouldn't be a
podcast without our sponsors and I want
to welcome Express VPM to the show VPN
to the show because when they approached
me I read the information and I think
this is just tremendous because internet
privacy is [ __ ] dead it's more and
that's the reason why I use Express VPM
it runs in the background of your
computer or your phone and then you can
use the internet just like you normally
would you download the app you click to
connect and viola you're protected
alright the features your totally
anonymous
there's no location tracking and it
shields your identity and to me that
means the [ __ ] world and how do you
get it here it is nice and easy you
download the Express BPM app on your
computer or your phone you push one
button and boom viola you're protected
it's less than seven dollars a month and
you get a 30-day money-back guarantee I
don't give you nothing unless you got a
guarantee so everybody feels good all
right everybody feels good when you hear
it on the Church of what's happened now
so listen find out how you can get three
months free at expressvpn comm slash
Church that's CH you are CH and that's
expressvpn expr e SS VPN dot-com slash
church for three months free when you
buy a one-year package is that simple
visit expressvpn comm slash Church to
learn more and take back your privacy
visit expressvpn comm slash Church be
protected be safe
be confident and take back your privacy
that's expressvpn comm
slash Church listen I told you once I
told you a million [ __ ] times about
CB deal it's like getting ging Singh 20
years ago remember you could buy a crack
pipe next to
saying how healthy is that [ __ ] ding
zing I'm sure when that [ __ ] Tibetan
monk invented ding zing he wanted
marketed next to a [ __ ] crack pipe
with a rose in it yeah I'm talking to
you because picking a reliable CBD is
like [ __ ] pulling teeth it's like
meeting a woman with I chlamydia on
Sunset you know I'm saying it's not
gonna happen
lucky for you [ __ ] I got into
CBB line and if you see people on
Twitter hit me back these guys don't
mess around then make CBD products from
start to finish and they got your
covered whether you want to smoke a vape
whether you want to do cartridges
whether you want to do the shatter oh
you're not into smoke and forget about
it they got a gummy betting on a
raspberry gummy bear they don't make you
[ __ ] heads pop up every time you
understand me if you have that
hemorrhoid pop pop goes the weasel all
right
and I do the tension you put it under
your tongue an hour before you go to bed
at night forget about it and especially
if you do two of them you'll sleep like
a [ __ ] his ombo their products are
clean Bobby and they're not like these
[ __ ] face you see at liquor stores
and shoe stores and [ __ ] like this what
I want you to do first just to see I'm
not [ __ ] around go to CBD lying calm
check out that third party lab results
yourself if you don't [ __ ] like what
you see you take a hike but I guarantee
you're gonna like like what you see I'm
like I told you they make their products
from beginning to end so what I'm gonna
do for you today
I'm saving your [ __ ] life CBD line
comm pick something go to the box click
in church at checkout get 20% off BAM
Joey really yeah I'm telling you get 20%
off you little miserable [ __ ] you go to
CBD lion com put some happiness in your
life try the tension smoke the vape
whatever you want to do they got you
covered you know even my wife smoking
the [ __ ] babe she found in the book
of them when you go on the website they
have what ailment you have and what babe
you should smoke and she's been smoking
like I don't know Purple Haze or
something I thought you know
I know what I did this morning but do me
a favor just go to CBD line comm get the
party started and get 20% off all right
checked out all right I want to thank
CBD Lyon calm
I want to thank expressvpn I also want
to thank sip recruiter and on it for
having our back this week and always
having our backs but most importantly I
want to thank you mother [ __ ] savages
go to Joey Diaz dotnet for tour dates
but right now let's just focus on the
Lincoln [ __ ] Theatre in DC I'm not
coming to Baltimore say you [ __ ]
take the ride [ __ ] I'll see you guys
Monday mornings ready to rock tip top
ago I love you guys stay black Lee kick
this [ __ ] meal